welcome back now let's do some more
mechanical advantage problems and in
this video we'll focus on pulleys which
is another form of a simple machine and
we've done some pulley problems in the
past but now we'll actually understand
what the mechanical advantage inherent
in these machines are so let's say let's
start let me start with a very simple
pulley so this is a ceiling up here and
I have a little I don't they what they
call that part of the pulley I should
learn my actual terminology but let's
say I have you know that little disc
where the rope goes over and it rolls so
that the rope can go over it and move
without having a lot of friction and
let's say I have a rope going over that
pulley that's my rope and at this end
let's say I have a weight a 10 Newton
weight and I'm going to pull down on
this and I'm going to pull down on this
end to make the weight go up so my
question to you is what is the
mechanical advantage of this system what
is the force that I have to pull down in
order to lift this weight this 10 Newton
weight in order to Bruce 10 Newton's of
force upwards well in any pulley
situation and I don't know really
textbooks cover it this way but this is
how I think about it because you don't
have to memorize any formulas is I just
think about well what happens to the
lengths of rope or what is the total
distance that the object you're trying
to move travels and if you know the
distance that it travels versus the
distance that you have to pull you know
the mechanical advantage so in this
situation if I let's say if I were to
take this if I were to hold the rope at
that point and if I were to pull it down
I don't know 10 feet or some arbitrary
distance what happens over here well
this weight is going to move up exactly
the same amount right whatever I pull if
I pull a foot a foot down here this
weight will move up by a foot so the
distance that I pull here is equivalent
to the distance that it pulls up here
and since we know that the work in has
to equal the work out we know that the
force I'm pulling down has to be the
same as the force or the tension that
the Rope is pulling up here and we could
have done that when we figured
just when we learned about tension that
the tension in the rope is constant I'm
producing tension in the rope when I
pull here and that's the same pulling
force of the tension on the weight so
this isn't too interesting of a machine
all it's doing is I pull down with a
force of 10 Newtons and it will pull up
with a force of 10 Newtons and so the
mechanical advantage is 1 no no real
mechanical advantage although this could
be useful maybe it's easier for me to
pull down than for me to pull up or at
some point maybe I can't reach up here
so it's nice for me to pull down here
where I can reach and the object will
keep going up like like an F flagpole or
something like that so this could still
be useful even though it's mechanical
advantage is only 1 so let's see if we
can construct a pulley situation where
the mechanical advantage is more than 1
so let's say I have let's see I'm over
here at the top I still have that same
pulley that's attached to the ceiling
but I'm going to add slight variation
here another pulley here and now let me
do
actually let me whoops okay now I want
to do the other pulley down here say
here and let me see if I can draw my
rope in a good way so my rope starts up
pulling up like what going up like that
then it comes back down comes around the
second pulley and now this is attached
to the ceiling up here and the second
pulley is actually where the weight is
attached to and no no this is called a
10 Newton weight again although it
doesn't really matter what its weight is
let's figure out what the mechanical
advantage is so the same question and
this is really the question you always
have to ask yourself if I were to take a
point on this rope and if I were to pull
it let's say I would have I were to pull
it two feet down so let's say I take
this point and I move it two feet down
what essentially happens to the rope
well every point on the rope is going to
move to
feet you know it's going to move two
feet to the right I guess you can review
this way if you view that motion is to
the right but if this length of rope is
getting two feet shorter what is this
length of rope getting well this entire
length of rope is also going to get two
feet shorter right this entire length of
rope right here
but this entire length of rope is split
between this side let me do it in a
different color between this side and
this side so if this if I make this side
of the rope shorter I mean the rope goes
through the whole thing but if I take
this side of the rope and I pull down by
two feet what is going to happen well
this is going to get one foot shorter
this rope is going to get one foot
shorter this is going to go one foot
shorter and this length of the rope is
going to get one foot shorter and how do
I know that well this is all the same
rope and if this is getting one foot
shorter and this is one getting one foot
shorter it makes sense that this whole
thing is getting 2 feet shorter but the
important thing to realize if each of
these are getting a foot shorter that
this weight is only moving up one foot
one foot so when I pull with two feet if
I pull the rope down two feet here this
weight only moves up one foot so what is
the work that I'm doing well the work in
is the same as a workout and we know
what the workout is the workout is going
to be the force that the that this
contraption or this machine is pulling
upwards with and that's ten Newtons
so the workout is equal to ten Newton's
times the distance that the force is
pulling in times one foot oh why did I
do feet I should do meters that's not a
good thing that for me to do it should
be meters
I shouldn't mix English and metric
system so ten Newton's times one meter
so it equals ten joules and this has to
be the work that I put into it to write
so the work in it also has to be ten
joules the work into it also has to be
ten joules well I know the distance that
I pull down I know I pull down two
meters so I pull down two meters so this
has to equal the force times the
distance so
force which I don't know times the
distance which is two meters is equal to
ten joules so divide both sides by two
so the force that I pulled down with is
five Newtons so I pull down five
Newton's for two meters and it pulls up
a 10 Newton weight for one meter the
force times distance is equal to Force
Times distance so what was the input
force the input force is equal to five
Newtons and the output force of this
machine is equal to ten Newtons and
mechanical advantage is the output over
the input so the mechanical advantage is
equal to the force output divided by the
force input equals 10 over five which
equals two and that makes sense because
I have to pull twice as much for this
thing to move up one that to pull move
up half of that distance let's see if we
can do another mechanical advantage
problem actually let's do a really
simple one that we've really been
working with a long time let's say that
I have a wedge a wedge is actually
considered a machine which four it took
me a little while to get my hands around
get my mind around that but a wedge is a
machine and why is the wedge a machine
because it gives you a mechanical
advantage so if I have this wedge here
and this is a 30-degree angle if this
distance up here let's call this
whatever distance this is let's call
this D what is this distance going to be
well it's going to be D sine of 30 and
we know that the sine of 30 degrees
hopefully by this point is one-half so
this is going to be one-half D and you
might want to review the trigonometry a
little bit if that doesn't completely
ring a bell for you so if I take an
object if I take a box and let's assume
has no friction we're not we're not
going to go into the whole normal force
and all that if I take a box and I push
it with some force all the way up here
what is a mechanical advantage of this
of this system well when the box is up
here we know what its potential energy
is it's potential energy is going to be
the weight of the box right so let's say
this is a 10 Newton box
this is a 10 Newton box the potential
energy at this point is going to be 10
Newton's times its height right so
potential energy at this point has to
equal 10 Newton's times the height which
is going to be 5 joules and that's also
the amount of work one has to put into
the system in order to get it into this
state in order to get it this high in
the air so we know that we would have
had to put 5 joules of work in order to
get the box up to this point so what is
the force that we had to apply well it's
that force that input force times this
distance has to equal 5 joules right so
this input force oh sorry this is going
to be sorry this isn't 5 joules it's 10
times 1/2 times the distance it's 5d
joules right this isn't some kind of
Units it's 10 joules it's a 10 Newton's
times the distance that we're up and
that's 1/2 D so it's 5d joules sorry for
confusing you 5d joules and so the force
I'm pushing here times this distance has
to also equal to 5d joules right I just
remember I just used D as a variable the
whole time dividing both sides by D what
do I get the input force had to be equal
1 to 5 Newtons I'm dividing both sides
by D meters so I inputted 5 Newton's of
force and I was able to lift essentially
a 10 Newton object so what is the
mechanical advantage well it's the force
output 10 Newton's divided by the force
input 5 Newtons mechanical advantage is
2